Jarvis is in New Orleans
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Jarvis
hey David better than I deserve what's
up not a quick question so I just
recently got engaged in relations thank
you thank you
me and my fiance kind of disagree on
this one thing of course we're going to
get married
sooner than later but we're on baby step
two and she's wanting to take a are
going to honeymoon and I don't think we
should and I was kind of hoping you
could give me some perspective on it or
than that we should how much debt do you
guys have combined this about 120,000
and what is your combined incomes after
you're married well I make about 70,000
she's currently unemployed with cheat on
the market okay and you said a hundred
and seventy thousand dollars in debt how
much you say again no no 120,000 about a
thousand a what is that a big chunk of
it is one of her student loans like
60,000 mm-hmm
I have a car for one came on a bunch of
you know stupid you know and so what was
what is her field what will she be
making when she gets a job well she has
an MBA with a concentration in HR so I'm
thinking somewhere between forty to
fifty thousand so no I would hope that
or more yeah all right and so you're
going to be making like 120 how old are
you guys I'm 30 and he's 20 28 okay good
good all right and is there any help
paying for the wedding what's the
wedding look like no we're gonna have to
we're gonna cash for it and actually
that's that's another what are you
spending on a wedding like the capital
module about ten thousand dollars I'm
good thank you good and when are you
projecting to get married I guess
November of next year okay I wanted to
kind of go through December working my
desk overall because I got so fired up
and you know I just didn't want to
really pause it but I know we need to
get married you know there's no sense in
putting it off any longer
so I
day was like November of next year
because I wanted to get to December with
the death snowball and then start saving
at the beginning of next year for the
wedding so you're putting off 18 months
yeah I know you're going to say that
okay all right what I would do if I woke
up in your old shoes when wouldn't what
when did she just graduated you said no
what she graduated about a year so
though why is she not working she had a
job she was miserable there and we don't
have any kids or anything like that so I
was like if it's going to be a time for
you to make a career shift and now would
be the time so she just kind of quit her
job so that she could spend more time on
getting into something that she was you
know really wanted to do how long has
she been unemployed since January this
year that's a long time all right okay
she needs to find herself pretty quick
and get re-employed because you guys
have a mess and you have a wedding to
plan
so the way I answer questions on this
show is you know Jarvis is what would I
do if I woke up in your shoes if I was
38 and or 30 and 28 and I had 120,000
dollars in debt and I was making 70 and
my future wife is gonna be making 50 or
60 in the next month or so because she's
about to get a dad gun job I would put
the debt snowball on hold and I would
save up the $10,000 for the wedding I
would use 8,000 of it for the wedding
and 2000 of it for the honeymoon or
something like that but this idea that
you do zero honeymoon while you're doing
a $10,000 wedding then makes sense to me
I don't care if it's 12,000 or 11,000
that you save up ten for the wedding one
for the honeymoon it doesn't have to be
some kind of glorious thing you do not
have to go to Bora Bora for your freakin
honeymoon I mean you you can go around
the corner and over the hill and go down
to the Gulf Coast somewhere you know and
have I have a perfectly great honeymoon
it doesn't have to be super expensive
there's no correlation between the cost
of the honeymoon and the success of the
marriage none whatsoever
so but I think it is smart to budget
some of this wedding experience for
honeymoon I don't care if it's a
thousand okay it's 1,500 I don't care if
you change your ten thousand on a budget
to ten five I don't care what you do but
something in there but
we need to put a budget on the wedding
and a budget on the honeymoon the
honeymoon you know the more we spend on
the honeymoon the less we spend on the
wedding in other words and we then we
crank that up and we do that that is the
very first thing she gets the job and as
soon as that's budgeted and done I'm
getting married if I was in your shoes
I'm not waiting 18 months and you know
paying off all this debt you can get
married come home pay off the debt I
mean you're gonna be making 120 you paid
off in two years if you go if you're
completely focused on it
zero honeymoon is a bad play on your
part um even if it's 500 bucks to go
around the corner and over the hill the
Pensacola or something and you drive
over there and you rent you know the
Hampton Inn you don't have to spend a
ton of money I mean really it's not it's
not a big thing to spend it you don't
have to go to an all-inclusive in
Jamaica to be officially married it's
not required so anyway that's what I
would do if I woke up in your shoes and
I would put something in there and I
would move that to the front of the line
and you know the fast the faster she
gets employed the faster we get to that
goal and that's how I would do it